how funny would that be if he's like do
the murder I'll hide you they'll never
find you well he doesn't change his nose
that's not Nema or he gives him a BBL
he's like
oh my God
[Music]
here's a name that's showing up
everywhere I don't know if you guys have
noticed uh who is Nima momeni who oh no
more money
I didn't think of it that way uh Nema
momenti is a CEO of a tech company and
he is the suspect for the killing of Bob
Lee the uh cash hat
he just he's like another tech guy like
owns his own company
so they were thinking that Bob Lee was
just killed by like a random yeah they
thought it was like some homeless crazy
person you see the video of him trying
to get help that surface I saw the GIF
and I don't want to watch it there's
like security footage of like from like
an ATM of him like trying to get help
when he's like bleeding out and there
was a person that actually was driving
by and he got to the window of the car
and asked for help and they just drove
off well I would too a bloody ass dude
in San Francisco yeah that's scary so uh
yeah they've arrested the prime suspect
his name's Nima mumini and um there was
a like a day had passed before any
information came out and how the two are
related but then now there's a kind of a
narrative that's coming out of course
um I guess Bob Lee the cash app guy was
spending some time with Nema momenti's
sister who was married
and they don't yet know what exactly had
occurred but basically the night of the
murder maybe he was teaching her how to
use the app he's like so you could buy
stocks here you could also buy Bitcoin
yeah or maybe she she has a side gig on
only fans and then he's like you know if
you use cash app I can give you money
directly and only fans won't take a cut
[Music]
yeah so it's this kind of this this sort
of unclear thing that uh looks like
here's what it looks like it looks like
Bob Lee was sleeping with his sister and
it looks like Nemo momenti went to talk
to him
and stop [__] my sister she's married
there's a text record a text record of
uh the sister texting Bob Lee saying hey
sorry he came down on you so hard oh um
and I guess like there's record of Nema
grilling Bob Lee about like hey did you
make her do drugs did you make her do
anything inappropriate
um and then that night of the murder
they left the hotel they were at
together they left together in the same
car him and the sister no the sister
stayed back Nina momenie and Bob Lee
they went together in the same car I
think I don't know who was driving but
they leave in the car there's some kind
of a dispute and then Nema allegedly
stabs him in the chest and then that's
when you get to that video Yeah in the
car oh that's he was the one that hurt
him oh well enemies
because I thought the narrative was he
was randomly stabbed
from some homeless man in in San
Francisco they were thinking that
because honest
doesn't have a house right now he's in
between homes so technically yeah
he's driving from one home to another
really be the ones closest to you bro
damn [__] crazy yeah so there's
that's kind of the obviously the case is
ongoing but that's the Assumption now
it's in a it's a murder yeah that it was
some kind of oh I was gonna say you know
what's weird about his morals he's like
I don't want my sister doing drugs doing
any of this stuff she needs to be a good
girl now let me go [__] kill somebody
like what Bible Style baby what if Bob
Lee was doing some crazy [__] yeah what
if he was being a wild wild boy either
way obviously don't stab him but I'm
just saying like you know whatever
why does he regulate his sister like why
is he killing that dude is it like a
cultural thing like a venmo guy dude
apparently nema's sister who's married
she's married to this like successful
plastic surgeon their marriage may be on
the rocks
I think like maybe Bob Lee was kind of
slipping in there somehow he's the
rebound boy dude or not even rebound
he's the Let Me Get You When You're
vulnerable yeah probably with the D yeah
dude the guy who owns cash app can't get
you know such a regular single lady dude
hey when it's Love You Love Is Love San
Francisco love yeah who you follow but
now like people are kind of picking
apart Nima's whole like story because I
guess like in his record he supposedly
graduated from UC Berkeley and all this
stuff and then UC Berkeley saw that and
was like that dude ain't going to our
school so now like stuff's starting to
look weird with him so what is oh I mean
I guess a fake resume or something maybe
I mean he's he's well off too yeah even
if that happens in like right you go
after this dude like that's a pretty
[__] perspective on the world like
that you even got like you said him and
not your own sister like for
accountability like you're already kind
of [__] yeah yeah yeah right something
wrong man yeah nobody knows the exact uh
dynamic between all of them they don't
know if like the sister it was unwanted
attention they don't know that well
they're having a sexual relationship
right well we don't oh we don't know
that okay I see I see they don't know
that for sure so it could be that he's a
stalker and his sister's like this was a
thirsty [__] what it sounds like is
that Bob Lee and and the sister we're
gonna meet up and then Nema intercepted
the meeting and then and then it looks
like because it was like uh it was like
two hours of them in the hotel so he
probably like gave him a roast or
something or like came down in a prayer
that's what the text apology was about
she's like hey sorry about that whole
thing and then uh yeah it drives him
somewhere like I think he says I'll drop
you off at your hotel now and then they
drive off and then
oh [__] [__] dude but who knows every
day the story gets different and changes
so you know we'll upload this today and
then by tomorrow it could be a whole
different thing who knows it could have
also been like he actually dropped him
off and then some guy was just standing
out there what if that actually happened
yeah we don't know like yeah he goes
okay bye and then as soon as he gets out
a crazy homeless dude just starts
stabbing early yeah it's like that
series like a night of where the guy
goes on a date with the chick and he was
the last one seen with her but then she
gets stabbed up like that one night so
he's the only one that's at question
they still don't know what happened yeah
I mean we won't know until they give us
more details later right yeah I mean
they're it's ongoing right now they're
probably gonna get to the bottom of it
pretty quick there's been a lot of like
Silicon Valley drama like from the
Silicon Valley bank and then down to the
whole cash app thing yeah there's a lot
of evidence already that it's kind of
moment that's why they're so liberal is
just telling everybody everything but um
kind of a cool name though huh
it's a fun name to say yeah we've been
saying his full name the whole time no
memmy I wonder about I wonder how that
will uh affect a jury
Mr momenty
I'm kind of it is fun to say
I don't think he did it yeah yeah oh
that's the thing so like after the
reason why they know it's kind of him is
because he stabs them in the BMW he sped
away afterwards and threw his knife out
the way
glasses which is honestly these are
signs of like Crimes of Passion when you
weren't expecting to do this so it's so
sloppy you know what I mean like so it
sounds like he did it a hundred percent
they just need to really make sure of
all the evidence right they gotta get
rid of the Reasonable Doubt I imagine is
there footage of him throwing out the
knife uh surveillance footage yep okay I
don't know though a middle eastern guy
driving a BMW that doesn't sound right
dude he's never seen that before yeah
what and I feel like Nemo mini just has
a really unique relationship with his
sister or it may not be that unique dude
maybe he has a sister complex where he's
the one that's in love with his sister
and then any guy it's definitely super
misogynistic to you to like go after the
lover and not like about it like your
[__] sister was like a human adult
yeah like I'm stepping in it's
definitely like cultural yeah no I think
so I think there's a lot like some Asian
cultures do that same [__] isn't that
kind like called honor killing or some
[__] or or no when they do that that's
to their own yeah I think yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
sounds like an Assassin's Creed
achievement no that's like a thing they
do in India it's a thing when there's
like some extremists like community
these where if the daughter messes up
you kill then yeah the family kills
so so in this case it's it's they killed
the guy not the girl there was a famous
story in India about that where a guy
like he killed his daughter because she
was like dating some dude that he didn't
approve of [__] he like cut her head off
oh and like walked the streets and then
put it and he turned himself in at the
police department and was like I did a R
Kelly yeah that was like what is the
penalty for that huh just a high five
it's a high five and a pat on the butt
that was a good job
no I don't know I don't know what
happened after that but that was the
story yeah
yeah so maybe it could be that like um
Nema was or maybe it could be Bob Lee
was trying to do something with his
sister and the sister never did yeah and
Nemo was just sick of it it was just
like stop trying to protect my sister
blah blah stop stop stop so maybe that's
why he wasn't killing his sister the
only time I would okay this is if uh Bob
Lee was a stalker and he was thirsting
so hard and she's like oh you know
[__] stop bugging me yeah but then
why should she apologized to Bubbly
that's her as a sister that's the sister
and that's Nema that is her husband oh
okay yeah she's bad as food would you go
so far that's probably why I wouldn't
get stabbed in a chest for her yeah nah
you know but damn she's bad as [__] for
sure good for her yeah and that so Nema
was obsessed for sure dude I think on a
lot too where dudes are obsessed with
her own hot sister like in a protective
way oh really Steve Greenhouse yeah
Steve Green Steve Green that's his thing
really he always talks about how hot a
sister I heard something like that about
it yeah
I have sisters and I'm like you could
have her
I'll get Roy at anybody dude and it's
clear if she's texting Bob Lee like
saying hey sorry about that then it's
clear that it's not like uh you know
she's not disgusted by Bob Lee yeah
she's not actively trying to avoid him
she's really trying to maintain a
rapport what if this is like his always
his pattern uh nemus what's his name is
like this is his pattern like since they
were growing up she he'd always like
intervene in the relationships and then
she's like well you did it again
why'd you do it why'd you kill him this
time
well I ask you a question what if you're
the the plastic surgeon husband and you
how you find out about the situation is
the murder oh my God you hear that part
first and it comes back like oh wait my
wife what the [__] like all of that and
then you're at work the next day trying
to like slice somebody like what like
that's what [__] you're [__] up noses
and [__] you're like
I got a lot on my mind because what do
you do to get mad at her like you
through like the affair see I'm a
[__] like I'm too sensitive so part
of me would be so pissed but also like
damn my wife's boyfriend just got
murdered like I'm sure she's pretty sad
about that
[Laughter]
I feel guilty about this jersey yeah
yeah damn oh man that's when you need
Ayahuasca I think or maybe or maybe the
husband knew what the husband do oh he's
like yo kill them is crazy he read the
text like your sister what if he set it
up kind of yeah what if he knew nemus
was a hothead yeah so I'm saying he knew
and I'll hook you up with a new nose
later yeah
or he wants that leg that leg transplant
surgery he's right Nema wants five
inches of growth I mean it was you you
want those you break your tibia how
funny would that be if he's like do the
murder I'll hide you they'll never find
you all he does is change his nose
that's not Nema or it gives him a BBL
he's like I don't want that video oh my
God
never suspect hey Nina you do this
you're gonna have a big old dog dude
getting taller you sit down I'll be
unrecognizable
they make him stand up in the courtroom
your honor that is not Nemo turn around
nope
[Music]
foreign